a child who is allergic to everything
including air and water is admitted to a
place where he's supposed to get better
but he ends up discovering a horrible
secret behind his condition
so today on cinema recap i'll show you
eli a netflix movie
the film begins with a boy named eli who
can't even leave his own house because
everything outside causes irritation
that makes him feel like his body is
burning we see that he sleeps inside a
capsule as his mother promises him that
soon they will take him to a place where
he will be cured in addition telling him
that she loves him the boy cleans
himself and gets ready with a special
hazmat suit to be able to go outside we
see that his father has financial
problems and that when they leave a
hotel a group of men tease eli and cause
his suit to rip at the knee that little
scratch causes air to get inside the
suit making the child turn all red and
unable to breathe well but his mother
fixes the rip and helps him relax
telling him to think of a birthday cake
and to make a wish eli says in his
imagination that he wished that he could
hurt the men who bothered him as they
continue on their way to the doctor who
will heal eli the father says that such
treatment costs a fortune at the same
time eli tries to do a card trick on his
mother but he notices that she is lying
about him having pulled the right card
although the mother says she would never
lie to him they arrive the doctor's
house is very large and gloomy when they
reach the door eli has to enter first to
go through a decontamination chamber
after he is received by three smiling
women one of them being the specialist
who will orchestrate his treatment the
boy has many questions about the
treatment and when he asked if the
doctor has managed to cure all her
patients she only tells him that she
understands that he is nervous and shows
him to his room she also tells him that
the water in that house is filtered
better than bottled water so he can
finally take a bath after a long time
and as he slowly takes his suit off eli
discovers that it is true that he can
breathe normally in there and therefore
he is able to hug his parents after
years of not having been able to in the
evening the parents talk about how happy
their son was after taking off the suit
the woman is very hopeful that her son
will be healed saying that they should
have faith and the man replies that he
has always had faith but he says it as a
complaint at night eli sees a bug
outside his window and suddenly he sees
the condensation of someone's breath on
the glass as well he gets scared and
asks his parents if he can sleep with
them in the morning he gives everyone
details of what he saw although he says
he is not sure if he was asleep or awake
so the doctor only takes this as a small
hallucination we see that for his
treatment sessions his parents cannot be
present to support him his mother tells
him to make another wish and he says
that he wants to be brave later we see
that they take him to a room where they
weigh him and take a picture of him then
they immobilize him on a table and the
doctor explains that she is going to put
a special virus inside his marrow to
restore his immune system we see that
the process is very painful and while he
is resisting eli sees a reflection of a
ghost child and falls asleep when he
comes too eli feels his whole body is on
fire and the doctors are only watching
him however he suddenly wakes up again
safe in his bedroom we see a girl
throwing rocks at his window to get his
attention so eli comes downstairs to
talk to her through a glass wall the
girl tells him that she knows that he is
sick since all the children that are in
there are she also tells him that she
too likes magic tricks and performs one
in which she lights a fire out of
nowhere using a piece of wood eli asks
how she did it but she replies that
revealing that secret would ruin the
magic and that there are things everyone
must discover on their own the boy wants
to invite her inside the house but the
girl says that she would never dare
enter and also that the owner of the
place hates her she warns him that the
house is dangerous also telling him not
to talk to anyone about what they talked
about on his way to his room eli runs
into a ghost girl in the hallway which
scares him away but then his father
appears and tells him that he must come
back to his room that evening the family
dines together and says a prayer before
eating eli gets angry because they don't
believe he saw another girl but his
mother convinces him that it was just
another hallucination that night eli
sees another ghost in his room then
using his breath on the window eli
writes his name but the ghost erases the
e from the left and takes it to the
right creating the word lie soon after
the ghost girl shows up again and tries
to attack him but his parents arrive to
help him to recover from what they think
is another hallucination the doctor
insists that it's just a side effect and
warns him that as the treatment
progresses these effects will worsen
which worries the parents during the
second session of the treatment we see
that they immobilize eli again and that
they have to open up his head to be able
to insert the cure there as well
meanwhile the mother is praying when the
father mocks her and says it will not
help at all the doctor comes out and
tells her that everything is working
perfectly that night eli says that the
doctor is lying in that he feels worse
however when his father tells him that
whether he wants to go away and be sick
forever or stay to get well the boy
decides to stay at bedtime eli hears
strange noises coming from his bathroom
his nose bleeds and the power goes out
then a ghost appears and although he
tries to convince himself it is not real
the ghost locks him in his room scares
him and even throws a wardrobe with him
inside and when he comes out he sees
that the word lie is carved on the
wardrobe the adult scold him even though
he insists it was not his fault
later when he speaks to his friend again
she tells him that the boy who lived
there before him also saw ghost although
the doctor had told him that none of his
patients ever had the girl also tells
him that he should not trust the doctor
or his parents saying that she did not
see the previous boy after his third
session of treatment eli gets scared at
this and says that he must get out of
there although he doesn't know how since
he could not survive outside without his
parents
then he hears some noises and some ghost
children begin to drag him through the
house leading him to the front door eli
gets trapped in the decontamination
chamber and then the ghost open the
front door that leads to outside for him
but the doctor arrives in time to save
him from his allergies then the boy gets
angry with everyone saying that the
doctor is a liar and that his parents
should believe him he gets so angry that
he breaks a glass nearby and then passes
out when he wakes up eli is in his room
while the doctor says that they must
give him some sort of medicine before
carrying out the third phase of
treatment his mother offers to give him
the medicine and the boy tells her that
he is not crazy although his father
looks at him as if he was the mother
tells him that she believes that he saw
things but she believes that what he saw
was not real the child accepts this
explanation and also accepts a pill that
his mother gives him as they hug eli
looks at the word lie from a side angle
and realizes that it forms the numbers
three one seven meanwhile the doctor
burns the boy's special suit while
everyone is waiting for the third phase
of treatment one afternoon eli talks to
the girl again telling her that he
thinks the three ghosts want to help him
out and that they gave him the code to
the secret door the boy is also
suspicious of her so he asks her if she
is a ghost but the girl jokes and says
that she is real and that he has become
paranoid that night eli uses a password
to enter a secret part of the house
where there he finds a doctor sleeping
in a room meanwhile the parents talk
about the possibility of their child
dying during the third session of
treatment the mother says that she
believed that the doctor had saved all
her patients and that she cannot believe
that they were lied to about it however
the man responds that she is the guilty
one here and they begin to fight
meanwhile eli finds files in which he
sees that all the children before him
had died after treatment 3. a nurse
almost finds him but the boy runs off
looking for his mother to help him
escape we see that she also wants to
leave and has even put his suitcases in
the car but the doctor convinces her
that she is capable of saving the child
from his illness meanwhile eli tells his
father everything he discovered but he
ignores him and begins to tell him about
beautiful memories of the past the boy
is frightened and his father tells him
he is very sorry for what he will do
after which he injects him with a
sedative at that moment the nurses
arrive and take him away although the
boy yells that they are going to kill
him we see that the sedative doesn't
work and eli escapes and gets mad at
everyone saying that the ghost kids just
want to help him then eli runs to hide
in the doctor's room where there he
discovers that she used to be a nun in
addition he also finds a secret passage
that leads him to a kind of altar for
rituals the doctor locks him up in there
and we see that not even his mother
helps him the child begins to feel the
side effects of his allergies however
soon after eli wakes up and realizes
that his allergies disappear and that he
can breathe normally he yells at his
parents about it asking why did you lie
to him about the sickness shortly after
his mother comes down and tells him that
they tricked him into believing he was
sick to protect him from the outside she
also tells him that he must go through
with the third treatment and that she
will explain everything to him however
the boy tricks her hits her and runs
away he runs to the room where he sees
his friend from the outside trying to
break the glass to get out the mother
discovers that the place where her son
was imprisoned was for sacrificial
rituals while the doctors managed to
catch eli although her friend yells at
him to not be afraid that it's the
others who must fear meanwhile the
mother discovers the corpses of the
previous children so she takes the
doctor hostage to save her son the
doctor says that she can save him so the
father takes her side the doctor says
that what can be saved is a child's soul
then she tells eli that the illness he
suffers from does not come from outside
but from inside his body then the doctor
turns into nun mode and begins to read
the bible with the help of the nurses
throwing holy water at eli we see that
the child's skin becomes very irritated
by the holy water and when the doctor is
about to stab him she suddenly loses
control of her own hands and ends up
stabbing herself at that moment we see
eli stand up with eyes red the doctors
tried to escape but the boy with his
body red begins to control their bodies
making them levitate and turning them
upside down in the shape of a cross his
mother tries to calm him down while eli
asks for an explanation she tells him
that he was never sick that they
actually have been injecting him with
holy water for years while the bodies
levitating around them catch on fire the
mother confesses that for years she
wanted to have a child but could not
then she began to pray but since god did
not answer her she began to pray to the
devil who did manage to get her pregnant
eli's adopted father tries to kill him
but the boy kills him with his powers
then his mother apologizes for having
lied to him for so long he forgives her
and they leave the house together while
the boy sets everything in his path on
fire once outside eli can breathe
normally his friend is waiting for him
and tells him that she already knew he
was a devil's son because she is also a
devil's daughter but that she could not
tell him anything because satan demands
that each one of his children must earn
their place the girl tells him that she
can take him to meet their father she
suggests that the mother should drive
eli's mother is nervous but he like
calms her down by saying make a wish
just like she used to calm him down they
drive away as the house burns down
the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
the recaps of the best bizarre and
sci-fi movies my name is tc and i'll see
you in the next video goodbye